what up welcome to the trillionaire
club guys big deal here in the
trillionaire club
not only are you richer than the richest
man in the world
but also you can learn about the system
that helped this man obtain his lambo in
90 days yes that's right
uh pretty incredible stuff but before we
get into that we're gonna do something
that i want to call ethics tips
this is basically a lot of common sense
the golden rule is don't
be a piece of
[ __ ] basically don't lie to people
ladies and gentlemen so many of you are
out there
just doing the most ridiculous things to
try to get clicks you think that clicks
are
everything and are worth selling out for
or compromising your image and it's not
let me show you an example of what i
mean today this is what i
like to call the tick tock lie
i really don't want to play too much
this otherwise we're going to get
demonetized here
but it says i'll mute it here we go
when our clients make high ticket sales
without a webinar or funnel and you see
this lady freaking out
and oh my gosh look at them they're so
excited because they're getting high
ticket sales without a webinar or funnel
now somebody sent me this and they
pointed out look you have the coach on
the left-hand side smiling right you
have the family on the right-hand side
whose life has been changed but here's
the deal
it's fake that's right guys because if
someone pointed out to me someone else
is doing this too
and both of these people are lying about
it they won
[Music]
this is the same exact video which was
friday so friday monday commander so
much money come join my team right
you'll be
shouting like this family right here
you'll be
so excited but here's the deal this is
not about
anyone taking a guru's course this is
all stolen from a tick tock it says
posting because i love these videos and
this is the happiest i've been in a
while
for getting into my dream school this is
this lady getting into her dream school
and it's now being used as a reaction
for marketers pretending like it's their
course that got them to act like this i
mean watch again guys what would you
think if you saw this dude
[Music]
oh yeah i'm so happy for them except
this isn't real they said that's a lie
it's a lie
gotcha look anything dude these people
will do
anything for the sale it's unbelievable
don't do this
okay this is bad bad and then what's
funny is i saw this guy
who video we just watched talking about
oh
how do you think i get so many
testimonials have you ever had an issue
getting testimonials from your clients
if so i want you to stay tuned in this
video because i'm going to show you
exactly
how i get so many testimonials oh don't
worry
tanner chidster we know how you get so
many testimonials buddy
you troll over to that uh tick tock page
and you just go ahead and throw it a
little reaction
right here let's do one right now
but anyway guys that's the ethics tip of
the day
don't take reactions and pretend that
they're your customers
how this this honestly isn't that hard
but this ethics tip has been brought to
you by
our old friends over at info wars you
guys know i'm a media buyer for alex uh
obviously he wants to support the show
alex thanks for your support of the show
i didn't even know you watched
uh you know you have a message for these
gurus
you're upset about it what do you have
to say to them i'm here to ram heads
with you
i'm here to take you down my destruction
is the seeds of your sure destruction
fools thank you alex uh as always this
message has been brought to you by
crippling debt from my expensive 10
million dollar studio guys you may have
noticed the production value is
sick lately um i seem to be in these
incredible places that i
almost couldn't be physically and you
wonder how do you put up such a gigantic
studio well guys
i'm in you should know
i built a gigantic warehouse and all of
these sets are
physically built i'm physically in these
areas
and that's just what it is and we have
to pay for it somehow guys
money is a fuel unit don't forget you
must have enough fuel units to live out
your new lamborghini here in the
hollywood hills
but anyway guys let's get back to it
okay you want to know you're here for
the trillionaire club you want to know
how do i get a lambo in 90 days well
our boy the ray cartier is here to tell
you
now the first thing to know is he's one
of these lifestyle gurus now what do i
mean by that
i mean that he doesn't really talk about
how to make money he more just shows off
his lifestyle
and then is always saying like oh hit me
up if you want to know more like like
pictures like this
okay mind the business that pays you
okay
i don't what is that huh leverage the
system that pays you ooh
we're getting original now but
ultimately all this money has to come
from somewhere after all
he says that he didn't start with a
silver spoon in his mouth no he was
broke before he learned how to make this
money
here we go from being 10k in debt to six
figure income
wanna find out how send us a dm
nothing like a money counter to really
get us interested but my point is
you really don't know what this guy's
into until you kind of dig a little bit
more in you know
all these lifestyle guys are like that
you're like what do you do
besides take pictures like how do you
make money it's confusing
you're saying you're so successful
you're getting a lambo in 90 days how
my name is ray milano i'm a 26 year old
forex trader
and i've helped thousands of people
become successful in forex trading
come on dude
today i check off another dream of my
list
i swear dude this is just
bait for the 18 year olds out there who
want to get rich quick
they're watching this stuff like oh my
gosh
i don't need to go to college i don't
need to get a job
i'm gonna quit my whole career and go
join ray cartier cartier
how do you say it i don't know and it's
disgusting but it's also hilarious like
you're following this idiot what is he
actually
selling you right i can't i still don't
know
what is he selling education okay what
what does that mean
how did he learn to trade forex
okay so apparently a lot of this is
linked to this thing he does called sky
net legacy now it says new and improved
artificial intelligence trading so i was
like okay
that's what he does he's an artificial
intelligence trader which honestly
sounds cooler than it actually is you
know there's a lot of these trading bots
that make
nothing but i was interested in what
actually
this is so i went to the page
you get some generic thing so i got the
webinar
whatever i went to the webinar link now
this is where i'm doing the due
diligence for you guys
so if you actually go and sign up for
the webinar this is what you get to
an unlisted youtube video where it's
selling you
not on skynet legacy i thought this guy
had created his own artificial
intelligence that's what he makes it
sound like
in his advertising instead he's pitching
something called avoria prime
now i'm not gonna bore you with all of
this but basically he goes oh yeah we'll
meet the team you know it's this amazing
team that built this amazing trading bot
that you can use to make money
no questions asked this is what this guy
is selling you he's saying
you can be like me you can be rich if
you join a voya prime
they sell an alexander package and an
heiress package they're two trading bots
i guess they give you alerts
one is 267 now 189 a month and the other
is
a hundred and ten dollars a month
so you're thinking oh so
it's a product that's how people are
making money
or they're making money by trading no
also not that's not how they make their
money
this is this is actually and it took me
forever to realize this
it's just a multi-level marketing
company
it's all a front it's a front that's
right at the end of the day
after all this talk about wealth you
know living the lifestyle
it turns out that this is an mlm
and it's not even the first version of
this mlm it started as
silver star live i don't know if you
guys can see that
silver star live right here which
apparently ended in a 75 000
fraud settlement then they tried
rebooting it as ea economy
that collapsed now they're rebooting it
again under this guy
now does that guy look familiar to you
he should
because that's this man right here sal
letto
he's one of the guys that marketed the
one coin ponzi scheme
and now he's trying to revamp this
failed trading bot
as avoria prime this is all according to
behind mlm which i find to be a pretty
reputable source
when it comes to investigating these
types of opportunities now what does
this all mean
well it means bezos is safe i mean i
really thought when i saw
the trillionaire club up here that bezos
has been cracked i mean as you know he's
not a trillionaire yet he's probably
watched this guy like hey do i have to
take this guy out have to drone strike
him
he's is he ahead of me in the game well
no this guy's another poser
trying to sell you with jealousy with
uh envy he's trying to sell you a
product and make himself rich and he's
trying to sell you multi-level marketing
guys
what are we in 2012 dude i thought this
avon
amway stuff was long dead apparently
it's all moved over to uh stuff like
forex stuff like that
don't bother with this stuff guys you
should know by now you should know
better
we here in the coffeezilla army we're
advancing the game so if you ever see
one of your friends getting into this
stuff
hey stop them you got to tell them look
friends don't let
friends get in scams that's it by the
way
also let me just say as an aside if you
can avoid i know a lot of people are
super into cars
but the more you can avoid getting
trapped by these and they are a trap
uh kind of like luxury desires
the less you have to work i mean all
these people they always talk about like
living a laptop lifestyle
you know the best way to live a laptop
lifestyle and to not have to work as
much
lower your expectations if you want a
lambo
hey guess what you're gonna be working
hard i'm gonna work
busting it all the time just so you can
have other dudes can look at you like
nice car bro but instead if you can just
be content
you know with the honda civic but it's
that sounds so lame
but you guys know what i mean if you if
you don't have to have all that stuff
guess what you don't need to work as
hard because you don't have these like
crazy expectations for life
that's why i think these things are
doubly stupid because on the one hand
it promotes like this like oh dude hey
bro just have cash and stacks and then
live this luxury lifestyle
and you have kids like idolizing this
stuff which is so stupid
but then at the same time they don't
make the money that they're saying
you need to make to get the lifestyle so
they're promoting this super expensive
lifestyle and
also not delivering sorry to get all
philosophical with you boys that's
basically it thanks for watching and as
always
don't forget to smash like and subscribe
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
comes along